I wonder obliviate it didn't work I
still remember this movie alright folks
the last film in my Harry Potter revisit
crimes of Grindelwald in this review and
I put that in quotes for a reason is
going to go a little bit different
because this isn't the only one that I
already had a review up on because I did
have a review for the first fantastic
beasts up before but it was old enough
and I had enough distance from that film
that you know I could really feel like
had given it a fair assessment crimes
are end of all didn't come out that long
ago and I went back and checked my old
review my thoughts have not changed on
rewatching it so rather than rehash a
whole bunch of broad strokes that you
can see in the original review instead I
busted out the pen I took notes and I'm
instead going to go through a bunch of
things that I hadn't noticed or had
forgotten or failed to mention before
some of these things might also be
repetitions of things that I mentioned
before but I'm just gonna run down a
complaint list because yes this movie is
not good like before I before I can dig
into this let me be clear on a couple
points one the inherent story threads
being utilized could have worked but
there's too many of them they're
stumbling over each other and this thing
does not feel like a properly structured
film if these same story lines have been
put into a novel that had the page count
for
to breathe maybe they would have worked
condense down into a film that doesn't
have a novel template to work off of but
instead trying to trying to do as much
as many characters as as many things
don't necessarily even need to be
together in one place it doesn't work
and the other thing I'll be clear on is
the acting is not the problem
everybody delivers a good performance
yes even Johnny Depp as Grindelwald so
those things are not the problem and
that I will even say that if they had
removed some of these plot lines and
focused out on fewer of them it could
even have been good but it's not it
stinks so let me get to this this one
I'm pretty sure I mentioned in the
previous review that opening is just
dark visual noise I'm pretty sure part
of the reason it's so dark and it's
raining and there's lightning is to
basically muddle the special effects
because as much as money as they spend
it's actually really hard to integrate
that sort of thing
as it's actually much harder to
integrate live people into a complete
CGI thing than it is to at this point to
take a CGI thing and put it in the real
world but that's what they had to do in
that setting because you've got this CGI
background and the carriage and the
thestrals but you have real people in it
and it probably looks like crap until
they add it all that stuff but now it
just looks like dark muddy crap the I
don't think the baby killing was
necessary you're actually gonna have a
running theme of things that I thought
yeah they didn't need to do that there
was no point they take over this muggle
house kill the people inside and they
kill a baby I don't think that was
necessary to go that extra step I don't
think anybody who was in doubt that
these were the bad guys that seems
needlessly cruel um it I feel like it's
a retcon that we find out that nude was
effectively in New York on some sort of
mission for a Dumbledore
it gets muddied a little bit when he
talks to Dumbledore and he's like well I
know you orchestrated it for me to be
there but I don't like how that rewrites
the previous film to a certain extent
because he just stumbled into what was
going on he was there for the creatures
because that's what he cares about and
now it's like this weird orchestrated
thing that Dumbledore put together and
that's unnecessary that adds nothing
the baby nippers are awesome I'll just
reiterate that the baby nibblers are
amazing and I want one okay she only
gets a couple of scenes but the
character of Bunty who I guess is newts
assistant has the line when he's going
to be going into the water says huh you
should take your shirt off and then when
she gets splashed with water she
literally gasps she gasps when she's
made wet it really annoys me when
awkward characters or characters who are
supposedly you know socially inept have
prospective love interest just tripping
over them it is coming in complete
contradiction to the characterization
and granted Bunty doesn't figure into
the plot but this thing has no less now
than free women basically tripping over
themselves for news I take the same
issue with a lot of spider-man's love
life to be clear this is not specific to
this film but man that does that drives
me nuts
okay Queenie and we're gonna come back
to this the starting point with Queenie
I think is pretty sound the idea that
she got back with Jacob and then
enchanted him makes sense because she
has a lot of insecurities about herself
and about her place and about whether
people are actually willing to be around
and stick with her so her do we meant to
him initially that honestly that's a
sound starting place goes off the rails
later but it starts out well enough oh
okay
why the heck does new take the nippers
to Paris like I know the real reason why
it's because Anne if leur factors into
the two what happens at the very end and
is a logistical thing but like no in
universe in narrative he leaves a note
for Bunty going to Paris I took the
nifflas
why why would you take the nibblers
there's no way it's one more thing you
have to keep track of once you get there
why would you do that it makes
absolutely no in story in character
sense it's only there as a logistical
plot thing for way later in the film
with
is very lazy contrived writing in yeah I
eat bad credence okay seriously cringe
probably has the story that I am the
most interested in finding out but they
skipped way too much his whole thing of
trying to figure out who he is and how
in what place he has in his world what
his history is actually found rather
compelling and Ezra Miller was a lot
more commanding on screen in this then
he was in the first fantastic beast film
but it has to share space walls so stuff
uh and they skip so far ahead we went
from oh maybe he died oh maybe he kind
of lived you now he's in Paris has a
whole other life set up and an
accomplice it's like we skipped at least
half another movie to get here any that
I would have been interested to see like
really irritating right there Oh which
of course brings up Nagini
ok huh so a couple things about Nagini
the the first is look I don't get I
don't get it that she's a sideshow
attraction because in a world that has
Transfiguration and animagus is anime
guy and a Magi whatever where those
things are very common what about a
woman who can turn into a snake is so
unusual that it warrants putting her in
a freak show yes I know she she's a
maledictis and she will eventually
become the snake permanently but the
Wizards present don't know they're just
taking the guys word for that for all
they know they're just watching an
animagus who can become a snake so what
about her is worth putting in a friggin
sideshow and also it's very strange to
me I didn't think about this before that
they make Nagini sympathetic that's just
weird and it's a it makes me feel very
odd about how triumphant it is that
Neville Longbottom basically be heads a
woman now retro actively that's what he
did at the end of Deathly house part two
I don't I don't know why I don't know
why the whole like Nagini period I don't
know why Oh what else we got oh okay so
huh it's said that Creedence is the only
creature who could kill dumbledore and
that's why Grindelwald wants him except
grinev all kind of has Dumbledore
covered with the blood thing but I will
come back to that not to mention the
fact the grin the vault has the Elder
Wand in any one-on-one combat scenario
any dueling scenario he's gonna win why
does he need this again maybe it ties
into the blood thing but I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna come back to that
so the Hogwarts scenes they are there
for no reason other than nostalgia I
will administer that worked on me and no
I'm not gonna bring up the fact that
McGonigle's it should be too young to be
a professor at this point because it's
something that I didn't know at the time
watching it and I wouldn't know if other
people weren't complaining about it
because they've memorized the ages of
characters because they know Pottermore
like the back of their hand
I'm not that kind of fan I don't care I
I understand what other people do get
upset about that if they do care I just
don't so for all my nitpicks I'm moving
on from that
why does Grindelwald have any particular
interest in Queenie
like he personally gets involved in her
temptation and he even tailors parts of
his speech to his followers and would-be
followers at the end - be sure to hit a
note that will appeal to her why does he
care about her I mean I grant he needs
followers in general but he clearly
doesn't care about his followers because
you know he has the guy who I guess
doesn't have enough faith birds in the
fire but even aside from that there's
one of his followers who moves against
the ores and gets killed for it
and he basically knew that was gonna
happen because and he wanted it to so he
doesn't take these people's lives very
valuable he has no reason to value
Queenie so why now we as an audience
value Queenie
because Queenie is awesome and Queenie
was great in the first film and Queenie
and Jacob is adore
we want that to succeed so we are
invested why is he why does he care
about this woman why is he putting
personal time into corrupting her I I
don't get it doesn't make sense
Polyjuice is way too common like part of
the reason that the film chamber secrets
yeah that that book that film got away
with Polyjuice is because there was a
lot of emphasis put on how hard it was
to make the the recipe was in a book
that was in the restricted section it
required a lot of complicated
ingredients it took a month to brew what
knew just happens to have some in his
pocket with his brothers hair so he can
look like his brother at any time
holy plot convenience Batman give me a
freakin break Robin needs to remember
that originally this stuff was supposed
to be difficult to get because now like
everybody has it you're gonna give
everybody a time Turner next might as
well at this rate oh god you want to
talk about pointless alright I'm
actually gonna tag two things together
here so there's a recurring thing of
things that are there for that things
are there to give a plot mechanic
logistical justification for something
that doesn't need it so example number
one newt tina thinking that newt is
engaged that misunderstanding why the
only purpose that i could come up with
for that is they wanted to pretend the
awkward sort of chemistry they had in
the first film and they figured they had
to roll back her comfort level cuz if
they just picked up where they were they
get more you know that it would it would
not feel the same if it would if the
relationship was actually moving forward
in some way except that newt especially
is so frigging awkward and tina so
uptight by the nature of their
characters it would have made sense for
them to be moving at a slow pace anyway
they didn't have to artificially come up
with some stupid contrived
misunderstanding that is zero impact on
the plot whatsoever in order to roll
them back and give them that chemistry
like they had just met for the first
time all over again
that's point
and the other one okay I told you I'd
come back to it the little blood thing
and like the oath that that Dumbledore
can't move against Grindelwald I
actually at this point hey that because
if you're Han JK rowling I mispronounce
it is Rowling before apologies old
habits
JK Rowling if you are going to continue
to assert that he is in love or was in
love with Grindelwald and that was a
deep emotional connection then you don't
need a magical reason why he can't move
against Grindelwald because the idea
that he worries that his connection to
this man that his love still lingers he
worries that he will falter in the heat
of the moment because of his emotions in
his history is a way more compelling
reason for him to not be able to move
against Grindelwald or for him to be
resisting it and fighting an new
absolute last resort he does not want to
have to go face-to-face with him because
he thinks he won't do what has to be
done because of his feelings for them
that is a way more baked in character
based compelling reason for him to not
move against rid of all then this stupid
artificial contrived nonsense you didn't
need it with the things you had him play
with the things we already knew you got
the same effect okay uh what else have I
got
oh speaking pointless huh little
estranges half-brother what was his name
Yousuf comma holy crap all he does is
deliver exposition except the exposition
he delivers isn't even accurate I went
into this in my previous review but oh
my god the frigging structure of this
thing where creedy's is like Who am I
Yusuf Khan and comment gives him this
whole long-winded explanation of who he
is and then immediately after is like no
none of that was true
great so you just wasted however many
minutes of runtime telling us that
because it wasn't true and you didn't
even let us live and think it was for
long enough that revealing that it
wasn't true has any meaning the thing
that you were just told is in fact not
true well I had any
digested it so I don't care Oh God
so like his entire character absolutely
pointless like it's not a misdirect if
you undercut it that friggin quickly Oh
God
what else it what else do I have it oh
okay um props to this the lead is line
to Newt you never met a monster you
couldn't love that is a legitimately
good line I will I will give this thing
credit where I can when I can
there aren't many instances um queeny's
entire turn is unjustified he doesn't
work again if there were fewer
storylines in this thing and they
focused on her a bit more they could
have justified it I could have bought it
because they could have focused on a
deterioration of her mental state
instead they pinned it on the idea that
she really wants to be with Jacob but
then it makes no sense because once he
rejects her because this entire thing is
scaring her that removes her motivation
to side with Brenda Valle but then she
does it anyway and I'm not saying it
would have been impossible to justify
that but you would need to have a spend
more time with a character so that we
could understand why she would still
make that choice regardless hey I didn't
do that okay oh the fire drag is at the
end of blue fire Dragons and they fight
with the red fire and they cancel my
stupid pointless it's there for the
wants of a more action II climax because
we've already had the theoretical
emotional climax if it worked for you at
all which mm-hmm but you know that was
just that's just CGI noise as far as I'm
concerned the blood oath I talked about
that
oh yeah the nibbler that you just
happened to bring to Paris just happen
to escape but the right time and just
happen to grab that one shiny thing holy
freaking coincidence okay the one less
thing I'm gonna talk about here so like
I've said repeatedly there's too many
stories vying for space now I do I did
finally kind of see how maybe they
thought this was the way to go because
between Creedence his identity and the
hunt for him and Grindelwald you know
trying to gain power and Queenie's fall
and leta and her baggage they were
constructing these parallel stories of
the kinds of people who would join
Grindelwald cretins needing acceptance
Queeny you know terrified of what she
might lose and lead up almost signing
with Grendel Walden she's got loads of
baggage and damage and so but then she
also shows that not everyone is
completely susceptible so between those
and showing how grin Duvall builds his
power and the fact that I actually think
Johnny Depp does a decent job in the
part I do see where there's kind of a
point to it but again it doesn't feel
focused enough and you'll notice there's
a name I didn't mention in that noot
noot has no place in that story he's
just here because he was here in the
last movie his entire presence in this
thing is completely unneeded unwarranted
not justified by the narrative that is
going on in here or the narrative that
appears to be pushing forward he's just
there and it's a shame because Eddie
Redmayne is pretty damn good in this
part and the stuff with the magical
creatures is some of the more enjoyable
stuff from the film but we're many kind
of narrative plod forward momentum
perspective it's also the most
superfluous and it could have all have
been scrapped and the overall plot would
have stayed exactly the frigging saying
this movie socks crimes Brenda Falls I'm
done you seen it what are your thoughts
on it whatever they are chops let me
down in the comments let's talk about it
once it's tough to do
like subscribe support me on patreon you
support me at a high enough level you
can force me to watch movies that I hate
much like this review was hoisted upon
me so other stuffs to do as well you can
follow me on social media I've got
there's links to stuff and things click
on them or I don't at the end of the day
folks you're the council I'm just
running the meetings until next time
this council is adjourned oh my god I
never want to see this thing again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]